the Kardashian sisters store dash was  robbed et can confirm Kim Kourtney and  Khloe's retail store on Melrose in west  hollywood california was burglarized  Monday according to the West Hollywood  Sheriff's Department deputies were  called to the shop to investigate a  theft the watch commander told ET the  items stolen totaled 14 hundred dollars  stop the robbery just so happened to  take place on the same day 17 people  were identified and detained in relation  to Kim Kardashian's Paris robbery on  Tuesday a source close to Kim and her  husband Kanye told ET the reality star  is deeply relieved to know that this  horrible ordeal will all come to an end  soon  you